but we probably should get you through
the weekend weather-wise so your most
accurate weather now forecast we've
changed our camera this is on top of the
red rock resort
looking out to the east you see not as
much smoky haze there's still a little
bit out there
our current temperature is the high so
far we'll get the official high
temperature at five
we are expecting to top the triple digit
mark because it's been i think it was uh
first of july was the last time we had a
high
under 100 degrees look at the low this
morning a very comfortable 74 so the
early mornings are great for getting out
and do whatever you need to do
to walk the dog or go for a run or
whatever so
we wanted to talk about the perseid
meteor showers you know every year in
the month of august as earth takes its
trip around the sun
the path of our orbit takes us through
the remnants of the swift
tunnel comet and so that produces what
we call the perseid meter showers
because they appear to be coming from
the perseus constellation
but basically what's happening is little
pieces parts of the comet are bouncing
off the atmosphere and it's super
easy to go see them after midnight you
need to get away from the lights of the
city we're talking about getting out of
town maybe down to the dry lake bed at
gene or out at lake mead or valley of
fire or mount charleston
no special equipment binoculars
telescopes only get in the way
all you have to do is look up you can
see dozens of shooting stars
tuesday night and wednesday night okay
back to
earth here we go with the wildfire smoke
still a little bit of an issue
last check 30 containment on that apple
fire
also wanted to check in on your family
and friends across the nation here you
see the attempted monsoon
it is firing up a little bit over
eastern arizona and
much of new mexico some showers from
during the day are beginning to die down
for nebraska oklahoma and arkansas
but this yellow that is a severe
thunderstorm watch for the folks in
minnesota and you know we've had some
tornadoes
there were also a whole lot of tornadoes
and much rain we're talking about over a
foot of rain when
hurricane and tropical storm isis went
through the east coast
while there is more rain happening there
today not nearly as strong
let's go ahead and get you through your
weekend now the next seven days
so today was the last day of those below
normal temperatures
maybe up to 105 and 106 next week rocky
mercedes